[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
previously on model lifestyle
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
so I am crazy
[Music]
so here this is where AFI Fashion Week
is going to be African fashion
international you ready I'm ready are
you ready let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some actress they doing the makeup today
[Music]
[Music]
ah
busy with the show now he's gonna send
me in the front
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're in the car here in South Africa is
very very beautiful and around the way
we're gonna do a photo shoot for you
guys male model poses for suits so you
guys can check it out on my youtube
channel now
these trees were driving possible the
yucca Rhonda trees check their magic hug
beautiful now when it comes to
expression you have to imagine that
you're that person so imagine you're
walking you to a business meeting right
now you have that confident kind of look
sometimes they want you to be more
friendly more smile more inviting so
then you think about things that make
you happy for me something to think
about my wife
yes is the photographer answers also my
wife so it's like double points for me
anyway you get what I'm saying so
imagine that imagine that role it's a
little bit more like acting
[Music]
my two brothers are burnt here now
sometimes our lives look perfect from
the outside
but we all experienced some kind of pain
in this world
my oldest brother he was shot in South
Africa when I was 13 now the brother he
died in a car crash when I was 21
[Music]
losing them taught me so much about life
[Music]
I also lost my father very recently to
cancer
[Music]
I want you to know that if you have any
kind of pain I really have compassion
for you I understand what it feels like
[Music]
started to fall and well don't waste
your life because you never know what
day will be your last
I made this vid in the memory of the
greatest man I knew my dad Etienne
merits
but it's our
[Music]
you
[Music]